there's a quote that says the beautiful
thing about learning is nobody can take
it away from you but what good is
learning if the knowledge might hurt you
drive you mad or even kill you it just
sits there in your mind like a stick of
dynamite with an invisible fuse it could
blow at any moment all it takes is a
careless slip of the tongue and you
might turn into a talking home appliance
this is a conundrum faced by anyone
dealing with an info hazard a certain
kind of anomaly often dealt with by the
scp foundation before we get into some
of the craziest examples of info hazards
and what they've done to people because
let's face it that's what you're really
here for first we have to answer that
big question everyone's a little afraid
to ask just what is an info hazard and
how does it differ from a far more
common type of scp the dreaded
cognitohazard well we're glad you're
finally brave enough to ask first
cognito hazards are anomalies that are
dangerous to perceive through one of the
senses a well-known example is scp-096
which is actually a visual cognito
hazard you see its face and your toast
it's as simple as that incognito hazards
exist for all the other senses too
hearing taste touch even smell info
hazards on the other hand are different
these anomalous effects are triggered
when you start trying to express or
describe something about what you've
perceived and when you do things start
to get really weird really fast maybe
you're trying to explain what you just
saw to family members friends or the
police maybe you're a member of scp
foundation staff trying to write up a
report or a new experiment log or maybe
you're a youtube channel trying to
create entertaining yet informative
breakdowns and explanations of anomalies
from the scp foundation if any or all of
these apply to you then info hazards are
going to be your worst enemy but as we
look at some of the strangest examples
we'll try our best to resist their
effects first seeing as it's so hot out
how about we take a relaxing dip in the
pool while we tell you all about
scp-1128 what is scp-1128
well that's a loaded question
technically speaking it's a massive
predatory aquatic creature but despite
its huge size the creature can hunt its
prey in any body of water whether you're
stepping in a puddle relaxing in the
bath or say chilling out in the pool
scp-1128 can track you down and
potentially eat you alive in one
particularly horrifying test a d-class
was drinking from a simple glass of
water when the aquatic predator emerged
yanked them inside and ate them okay so
maybe you're feeling a little nervous
now but don't worry you're still safe
some people have even survived their
attacks from scp-1128
while their initial attacks anyway the
creature has a tendency to come back
again and again relentless in its
ravenous hunger for human flesh whenever
it attacks successfully all that's left
is some blood floating on the water but
again please don't worry too much about
this creature we don't have another 682
on our hands after all it's an info
hazard it can only start hunting you if
you receive a written or verbal
description of the creature oh or some
kind of visual representation of the
creature too
actually on second thought you might
want to get out of the pool
now
and put down that drink too
instead let us tell you a nice little
story you step into a bar spelling of
fine liquor and rich mahogany you even
get a whiff of some fine leather-bound
book you see us sitting at the bar
motioning for you to come over and you
decide to approach you're intrigued by
our winning smile and our vast knowledge
of anomalies and scp foundation lore you
take a seat next to us and order a drink
get something fancy it's on our tab
after all our treat what does this have
to do with info hazards you ask
that's the thing about
scp-1893 kid we say are dulcetones
smoother than scotch you can never just
talk about it it's an info hazard that
forces information about it to be
delivered like a story that's why we're
in the spa right now that's the setup it
expresses actual information about
itself through the dialogue see you nod
beginning to grasp the concept as the
bartender serves you your drink it's
been forever since you've been to a bar
feels good to be out again honestly you
drink deeply savoring the flavor but you
almost choke when you see the man
standing in the corner he's so large and
so distinctive it surprises you that you
hadn't noticed him before now he stands
in the corner a freakishly tall and
muscular guy like a basketball player
who decided to become a pro bodybuilder
his muscular arms are bulging out of his
white vest and a pair of bull's horns
are tattooed across the top of his bald
head making him look like the devil made
flesh he stares at you with a subdued
kind of annoyance as if to say that
you're not in real danger quite yet but
if you wanted he could grab you and
twist your head off like a bottle cap
what's with the huge guy you ask us more
than a little concern in your voice oh
him we reply with the smirk he comes
with the anomaly he appears in every
scp-1893 experience to an extent though
his level of involvement varies if
scp-1893 doesn't perceive you as an
annoyance or a threat then you're good
to go but if 1893 starts to feel like
you're gonna cause it some problems then
the guy with the horn tattoos is gonna
intervene
speaking of which you look up and you
see that the giant man is now standing
next to you brow furrowed invisible rage
he picks up your drink and crushes the
glass in his hand without flinching
dripping booze and blood onto the
counter he snarls i think you've had
enough buddy now it's time for you to
leave we're gonna have to get physical
gabish you don't need to be told twice
you grab your hat get up and leave the
bar abandoning us on our lonely stool
but our next info hazard still awaits
you like poetry
japanese poetry yes
the humble haiku
it's dear 931 a unique info hazard
it's so poetic though specifically it
takes the form of haiku so what does
that mean a rigid structure the first
line five syllables then seven then five
we can't talk about this in ways other
than haiku it is challenging object
class is safe it is kept at site 19.
need third tier clearance so what is
this thing scp-931
it is a rice bowl white with a blue band
and a cracked blue pattern all inside
the bowl and we must confess we took
that one from the file man haikus are
hard 3 inches in height 4.5 inches
across metric doesn't fit no maker's
marks found suspected to have been made
late 1900s
really makes you think on the skill of
these poets sans anomalies sure it can't
kill you but writing these drives you
mad curse931
trapped in this rhythm scheme makes the
old man's torture world look like a
resort okay let's move on other scps to
see we're sick of haiku okay back to
normal time to shake off the structures
of scp-931 and talk about another iconic
infohazard
scp-3007 this incurable info hazard is a
lot less whimsical than a rice bowl that
forces you to write and speak in haiku
in fact it's literally killed seven
people and some in surprisingly gruesome
ways the main component of the info
hazard is known as scp-3007-1
this is an extremely vivid anomalous
hallucination that affects those under
the 3007 umbrella known as scp-3007-2
to be afflicted with
scp-3007 is a truly horrifying and
debilitating condition the
hallucinations occur at an average of
four times a day with each episode
lasting for as long as an hour and
during these episodes the victims are at
risk of grievous bodily harm or even
death so the question now is what
exactly is the
scp-3007-1 hallucination to the people
experiencing it they appear to be
transported to a strange alien world
consisting of a huge number of white
towers or pillars stretching into the
sky
scp-3007-2 specimens are trapped on a
series of bridges incredibly far off the
ground that connect these various
structures this anomalous area is known
as scp-3007-3
it is important to remember that people
transported to this world still remain
physically in our own however any damage
sustained with
scp-3007-3 will carry over into our own
reality to give one particularly
gruesome example some people fall from
the precarious bridges and tumbled to
their deaths in scp-3007-3
back in our reality they suddenly
explode from the damage of an invisible
high-speed impact killing them instantly
there's much more to scp-3007
enough that it probably warrants its own
explanation and the scp foundation takes
it extremely seriously believing that if
the info hazard is allowed to breach
containment and become contagious it
could result in an xk-class
end-of-the-world scenario as a result
anyone found to be infected by
scp-3007 is contained and summarily
terminated to reduce the risk of its
spreading to make things even worse
there are also concerns about scp-3007-3
seeping into our reality as those
standing within a two-meter range of
scp-3007-2
during a 3007-1 episode can actually
hear the sounds from the terrifying
hallucinatory reality okay that was a
little scary how about instead of
falling to your death without falling at
all we talk about a nice movie gonoshov
by martin scorsese one of the best
gangster movies of all time wait you've
never heard of ganesh rav it's got
everything action suspense romance a
mountain of black thorns on which lives
a dark tyrant of terrible and unknowable
power you sure you've never seen ganesh
rev well here's the thing all signs
point to movies like ganesh revs and
many others simply not existing this
comes as a result of scp-2747
an info-hazardous phenomenon that causes
people to talk about works of fiction
that don't exist these works often
feature commonalities like an ethereal
or disturbing tone ambiguity black
thorns and a sinister mysterious
antagonist the foundation is doing all
they can to hunt down and suppress
scp-2747 but it's proving more difficult
than they'd imagined currently the
leading hypothesis is that these tales
may have actually existed once but were
erased from reality leaving only the
residue of memory and the odd scrap of
evidence around many researchers
speculate that the various pieces that
form
scp-2747 are anaphabla pieces of fiction
accidentally composed with the perfect
elements to cause them to quite
literally erase themselves over time now
the greatest concern that the foundation
has about these anafabulas is that they
might actually be one and their reality
is on the precipice of collapse but we
really don't have time to unpack that
right now and like
scp-3007 a full explanation of this
anomaly would take some time and is
probably best tackled on its own but
there you have it folks info hazards
they all say that knowing is half the
battle but in this case it is the whole
battle and if you know you lose not
really a battle at all come to think of
it more of a trap but whether it's a
vicious mega fish a strangely buff man
with bull tattoos a poetic rice bowl or
a nightmarish ordeal of daily
hallucinations there is no doubt that
infohazards are some of the most strange
and fascinating anomalies that the
foundation has to offer oh and of course
how could we forget the most well-known
infohazard of all scp-2521
this entity is so infohazardous that its
foundation file entry is written in
pictograms this is because whenever
information is recorded about this
entity it manifests and steals it if you
write it down it'll take the paper if
you make a note of it on a computer
it'll take the computer and of course if
you talk about it it'll
oh no no no no no no no ah
oh that was a close one
but i'm okay
for now at least
but don't worry about me go check out
scp xk class end of the world scenarios
explained and all the little misters
explain for more collections of
fascinating anomalies